thanks to nebula and curiositystream for
sponsoring this video
an extended version of this video is
available right now on nebula
ah kyoto seat of the japanese government
for 11 centuries
famous for its 2000 temples and shrines
for its
rock gardens and for one of the most
important
but flawed international treaties of all
time
in 1997 193 countries signed the kyoto
protocol
formally agreeing that scientific
evidence indicated global warming was
taking place
due to human emission of greenhouse
gases and that we should do something to
limit those emissions this was hugely
significant it was the first time that
countries agreed to do something about
lowering greenhouse gas emissions the
protocol tried to be clever about how
they did this
while recognizing that more work was
required in the future it only required
action from developed countries
and required more action from the more
polluting countries though
shared the load between all wealthy
nations one way that the kyoto protocol
attempted to accomplish this was through
the idea of emissions
trading this is pretty simple each
country
is given a certain number of carbon
credits
with each credit allowing that country
to emit one ton of carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere
now if a country wants to emit more
carbon into the atmosphere than it has
credits for
it can buy credits from other countries
which
now can emit less carbon but have more
money
this means that if a country wants to
emit lots of carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere
they effectively have to pay a charge to
do so with that money
going to countries which have a lower
impact on the environment
so there's an incentive for countries to
lower their emissions
pretty clever this was a market-based
solution inspired by a similar one used
to limit sulphur dioxide emissions in
the usa
trying to combat acid rain which it did
very effectively
in fact america made the inclusion of
this emissions trading market
a deal breaker in the kyoto protocol
refusing to sign
unless it was included they got their
way and then of course
refused to ratify the treaty meaning
that they didn't have to abide by the
rule they insisted on
for everyone else to be more specific
there were three components to this
trading there was the basic emissions
trading that i just described but also
the cdm the clean development mechanism
where
rich countries would pay developing
countries to undertake projects that
would keep their emissions low
investing in renewable energy things
like that there was also
the joint implementation scheme where
rich countries would collaborate
together to jointly try and keep their
emissions
low it sounds pretty comprehensive using
the power of market forces to tackle
climate change head-on covers all the
eventualities
rich countries developing countries
collaboration
climate change complete it mate however
it turned out this market approach was
pretty
flawed it succeeded in bringing down
emissions a bit
but not effectively and in fact the
markets
created under the kyoto protocol didn't
survive very long at all
the protocol came into force in 2008 and
by 2012 the clean development mechanism
the cdm
saw a complete market crash as did the
joint implementation scheme
it turned out that there were a number
of loopholes
exploits if you will in these market
trading mechanisms
and companies operating in countries
that signed up to the kyoto protocol
found these very quickly now i don't
know
a lot about exploits but i do
happen to know someone who does
hello ladies and gentlemen i'm the
spiffing brit and today we're talking
about some
absolutely game-breaking exploits and of
course everyone's favorite international
treaty
the kyoto protocol this is one of my
favorite international treaties to
absolutely break and believe me while
the intention of the treaty was
definitely to limit greenhouse gas
emissions we're going to talk about some
extra spicy loopholes that basically
reward the exact opposite behavior so
get yourself a cup of tea smash that
subscribe button and if you're feeling
particularly majestic you can even like
simon's video
now firstly let's talk about the
hydrofluorocarbons or to you and me
hfcs these are a happy family of
chemicals mostly used to replace cfcs
another family of chemicals don't worry
it's all sciencey but i'm sure you're
all smart enough to understand now these
chemicals are pretty unique because
sadly they have an unfortunate side
effect of destroying the ozone layer
which we
actually need to survive now hfc-23 is
an extremely potent greenhouse gas
eleven thousand times more powerful than
co2 and of course under the kyoto
protocol you can receive carbon credits
for destroying it so if you were to say
artificially create the gas
only to then destroy it you can
effectively farm infinite carbon credits
very spicy now how do you create hfc 23
euros well this is the best part because
you can actually create it as a side
product of producing hcfc22
what's that oh nothing very interesting
it's another chemical that's a minor
greenhouse gas but it also destroys the
ozone layer so just to be clear in one
easy step you can increase the market
demand for hfc gases and then of course
whilst trying to protect a dwindling
ozone layer and you can also get paid by
international governments to destroy the
side products
which happens to be hfc gas as well and
guess what cheeky buggers did this all
over the world
oh they are so cheeky they do love
destroying the environment but seriously
did they not consult anyone about this i
mean anyone can see that there's an
exploit in this you're rewarding people
for producing greenhouse gases
and then rewarding them for destroying
it they're going to create an infinite
loop to make money come on guys it's not
difficult but that's just one
example of an exploit this next one is
exceedingly spicy and it all uses
nitrous oxide this
is another greenhouse gas of course 300
times more dangerous than carbon dioxide
and under kyoto you can claim hundreds
of carbon credits by eliminating
one ton of nitrous oxide now of course
hundreds of carbon credits now i like
the smell of all of that money
in south korea example rhodia invested
15 million dollars in equipment that
destroys nitrous oxide
but that investment produced one billion
in carbon credits
now that's far more than should have
been possible and how do they do this
how did they convert 15 million into one
billion well it's very simple
firstly rhodia received carbon credits
for destroying the nitrous oxide great
job gold star you're saving the planet
so take some money
however rhodier is a company based in
europe and rodeo is a company that
voluntary chose to destroy nitrous oxide
and even spend
money on equipment to do so as such
because of a fantastic legal loophole
the carbon credits it received under the
cdm fell
outside of the eu emissions trading
scheme as far as the eu market was
concerned carbon credits were just
appearing out of thin air into rodeo's
account
and rodeo of course could do what all
the other companies do and sell those
carbon credits on the market
that meant roadie was being paid to
destroy nitrous oxide under the cdm
and paid to sell its carbon credits on a
different market in the eu
now that is totally and utterly broken
it's effectively double counting any
emissions reductions and then of course
allowing the selling of carbon credits
to other companies in the eu market but
these credits have come from
literally nowhere companies buying them
on in the eu market were doing so in
order to of course offset their own
emissions those emission reductions
weren't real it's like me buying a get
out of jail free card from my friend for
dumping oil in the sea
whilst my friend owns an oil out of the
sea pumping company which is located
really really far away oh and guess what
they've got a lot of get out of jail
free cards so i'm going to keep pouring
oil into the ocean
so by doing this rudy was being paid to
destroy emissions in korea
and then being paid again to allow
emissions in europe it's absolutely
crazy i could go on and carbon trading
is literally ridden with legal loopholes
and just companies that are exploiting
the ever living hell out of it and i
know it sounds crazy ladies and
gentlemen but it's almost like
capitalism doesn't have the
environment's best interests at heart
oh dear instead it has money at heart
and
i love money and that's why i'm
announcing that spiffco is setting up
its own carbon neutral company where
we're going to be pumping deadly nitrous
oxide out of the environment
and dumping it in france that'll serve
you right frenchies
anyway time to go clearly my ex-boy
powers are too great to use here so it's
naturally back to making simon cry and
civ again and trust me it's not
difficult
anyway cheerio
okay maybe he's right quite apart from
all of these exploits
and there are a lot of them there is
literally an entire interpol document on
the loopholes that companies found
and the colonial overtones of developed
countries outsourcing the hard work to
developing countries
in a system that the developed countries
designed themselves
and there are a lot of those too the
emissions trading scheme fell apart
because it was
never the right tool for this task
it had previously seen success in
curbing sulfur dioxide emissions in the
usa
limiting acid rain but that's an
entirely different kettle of fish to
limiting carbon emissions
generating sulfur dioxide is not a
fundamental prerequisite for our modern
standard of living like
generating carbon emissions is also the
scale of the problem is completely
different acid rain is a serious problem
but
climate change is potentially
civilization ending
and this was raised at the negotiation
table in kyoto
with critics arguing that in this
context an emissions training scheme was
like
abandoning climate change to the lore of
the jungle
it was just too important to do that but
thanks to the insistence of american
delegates at kyoto
with america going on to never actually
ratify the treaty
we ended up with a emissions trading
scheme a market-based solution
because remember capitalism solves
everything
but the fact is that capitalist markets
have one goal
maximize profits that's it and so
companies will exploit any loopholes in
a market to maximize their profits
it doesn't matter if the market was
created for environmental reasons
if profits can be maximized at the
expense of the environment
they will be this was so widespread that
one estimate states that only two
percent of cdm projects had a high
likelihood of actually reducing
emissions many schemes ended up
increasing carbon emissions overall
through funneling money to extractive
industries such as
coal mining and even directly to
coal-fired power plants if they just
claimed their technology was the most
efficient
type which is a bit like giving out
awards for best films and
giving one to transformers because it's
the best in the transformers series
but a flawed solution is still better
than no solution at all right well
yes the kyoto protocol's emissions
trading scheme did
reduce greenhouse gas emissions a bit
but that's ignoring the fact that there
were other
better solutions that almost certainly
would have resulted in
a greater reduction in greenhouse gas
emissions
if you want to implement a global
climate solution that uses market forces
to drive down carbon emissions
then implement a carbon tax a set price
for every tonne of carbon that's emitted
such that products or services that take
more carbon emissions to produce than
others are more expensive
and the price of carbon gets higher
every year over time the products that
take the least carbon to produce will be
chosen by consumers
and emissions will fall that is a topic
for a whole
other video and does of course have its
own problems but
in my opinion and i think it would be
safe to say the opinion of the majority
of environmental economists
a carbon tax would have been far
preferable to the emissions trading
scheme implemented by the kyoto protocol
thanks america the lesson here is that
we still
need to lower global greenhouse gas
emissions and doing so
will require new solutions simply
rehashing solutions from previous
environmental problems
isn't good enough it won't work because
we've never faced an issue
of this scale of this complexity before
it can be done
but as we've seen at least on a global
scale
carbon emissions trading is not the way
to do this that being said there is one
very significant carbon emissions market
that has arguably been
a success the european union emissions
trading scheme operational for the past
15 years the eu ets
has been far more positively received by
economists and environmentalists
than the global market under the kyoto
protocol but why
why is the eu ets viewed differently
well i talk about this in a coder to
this video over on
nebula both smith and myself are part of
the large team of creators behind
nebula a streaming service designed to
be the expansion pack for the smart part
of youtube
how is it an expansion pack well it
features extra content
such as the extra part to this video
entirely exclusive content
such as my recent video on the carbon
footprint of noted streaming site horn
pub
and best of all it's completely ad
free you pay a small subscription fee
and get to watch the part of youtube
that you already watch
but in higher quality early and with no
adverts
at all but wait there's more we've
partnered up with curiositystream the
home of the best documentaries on the
internet with a deal
if you sign up to curiosity stream say
to watch miniverse chris hadfield
driving across our solar system
scaled down to the continental united
states with some guests
then you get access to nebula for free
so how much does it cost to get access
to not one but two of the best streaming
websites on the internet
five dollars a month nope just
14.79 a year that's
just over one dollar 20 cents a month
frankly this is far too good a deal to
pass up on so
make sure that you go to
curiositystream.com simon clark
linked in the description below to sign
up upgrade your viewing experience and
directly support the educational content
on this channel
thank you to curiositystream and to
nebula for sponsoring this video
thank you so much for watching this
video i hope that you enjoyed it i know
that i certainly had a whale of a time
working with my friend spiff on a video
i don't think anyone's made this kind of
content before i'll be the first to
admit that i am not an economist i am an
atmospheric dynamicist
so i hope you'll forgive me if i made
any errors in this video i tried my best
to sum up the literature
on the subject to a lay audience that
said if you do have opinions on the
video please do let me know down there
in the comments i particularly welcome
opinions
from people who know a lot about
environmental economics and could
further this conversation if you did
enjoy the video then please do pop it a
like you can subscribe to the channel if
you'd like to see more videos like this
and if you haven't heard of smith before
then um yeah check him out he'll be one
of the links up here along with some
other recommended viewing
if you haven't met him before you're in
for a wild ride thank you again for
watching
and i'll see you in the next one